welcome everybody i know a few people
are going to be struggling in thank you
everyone for coming on this last
thursday of february
so we're going to get started just a
moment going to do my normal
announcements then we'll go into the
talk
uh first thing i always do when this was
in person we would ask who is hiring
now unfortunately we can't have just
someone stand up and say hey i'm hiring
anymore because you know
or on the screen
so if you have a job and you're looking
to hire people go to the slack we have a
slack and the best way to get to that is
nyhakr.org
slack.html and there's a link there to
join our slack team
and once you're in the ny hack our slack
which is just
nyhakr.slack.com assuming slack isn't
down
you can go to the job postings channel
it's job dash postings and you can post
your job there
i'm just going to scroll really quickly
here i see a job open up here for
openlifeside.org
i see the council state governments is
hiring i see it looks like our open size
hiring
and that's just a few that i can scroll
up to a blue rose research
our studio all sorts of good jobs posted
there so if you're looking for a job go
to the job postings channel and find a
job so we bring people together like
that over the past what is it 12
13 years of this meetup
we have gotten so many people
jobs and let's keep that going so job
postings channel
self-servingly since i am on camera i am
hiring i'm hiring for a data engineer
i'm hiring for an account executive i'm
hiring for data scientists a shiny
developer
part-time full-time new york remote
wherever you're looking for i am hiring
a bunch of roles mainly data engineer
and account executive though you always
have other roles open as well if you
want to apply for a job with my company
landeranalytics.com careers or message
me on slack uh get in touch we're always
looking for good people
so this wouldn't be the meet up without
pizza
i got my pizza from antamos i'll try to
get that in focus
there it goes focus right there now it's
been sitting on my desk for about 10
minutes so we should have very good
cheese lock let's see yep good cheese
lock not falling out of place oh lots of
oil dripping and we have some good
charring on the bottom this is a gas
oven place it's like a gas deck oven so
everyone else is having pizza from
somewhere fun let me know in the chat
where you're getting pizza from or if
you're having some inferior food let me
know that as well
if you have some sort of great beer or
soda or milkshake or whatever it is you
want to imbibe in let me know where you
got that from too
we're always excited to know what people
are doing for those of you that don't
know when this used to be in person
every meetup we started with pizza and
beer if you didn't drink beer we had
soda and water um and i missed those
days so i but every month i still get
pizza hope to share a few folks so i
hope you folks have good food to share
with me
we have a
next few meetups planned march 31st
will be bill gold talking here's a
hybrid talk um part of it's about the
brooklyn bridge and how that relates to
data science and it's going to be really
cool so march 31st here on zoom thank
you to by the way ecohealth alliance for
continuously providing us the zoom for
the past two years and yes this
next month we'll mark our two years
doing this virtually march 2020 was our
last in person meetup and march 2022
we're still virtual
that's bill gold march 31st
we are hoping
in april to be back in person and
virtual we will do both we want to make
sure people from all around the world
can attend we are hoping to have an
in-person component starting in april
we are trying to lock down a venue we
have a few different places our our
go-tos before the pandemic we're hoping
they'll let us in we don't know yet so
if you have an office space in manhattan
that can hold a hundred plus people uh
seven o'clock on a weeknight
let me know let nicole know we would
love to use your space
and you could be there to welcome us for
our first in-person meetup which by the
way the april meetup if we return to in
person that marks the 13th anniversary
of the meetup so you want to host the
13th anniversary you really do
especially once you hear the speaker
it's david robinson
david robinson it's going to be for us
here to return us back to in person back
to new york city the city we love so
much and don't worry all of you people
attending virtually we are still going
to be doing virtual either on youtube or
zoom
using slack the way we're doing it now
we're going to keep this thing virtual
for you know virtual component forever
before the pandemic we tried live
streaming we couldn't get the audio to
work out right but we figured out the
audio during two years of pandemic so
we're going back live and in person i'm
really really excited hopefully it
happens assuming the omega variant
doesn't come or offices don't shut us
out so please give us an office space
we will announce the may and june meet
up a little bit later but we do have in
june our in-person conference we've had
two virtual new york r conferences
we are very excited to have
it back in person and virtual it will be
both we are going to the french
institute in midtown east we have tons
of food tons of drinks tons of just fun
activities we have great speakers coming
we have two workshops already announced
we have two more workshops who are going
to announce in the next week or so we
have great speakers with speakers like
john keane west mckinney we have osuma
tumi we have jennifer hill max [ __ ]
andrew gilman
it's going to be a great time and by the
way folks it is our and friends there's
going to be a python talk there will be
a sequel talk yeah python happens here
we'll have probably a julia talk and
it's maybe not julia we've had that in
the past but i don't know if you have
julia lined up this time we might have
sequel or stan it's gonna be r and
friends folks we're an open source
programming meetup the conferences are
and friends so come one come all
if you want to attend go to rstats.ai
for tickets we have early bird special
still running until i think march
11th you can get early bird tickets and
on top of that since you remember the
meetup and this conference is meant for
the meetup you can get a 20 discount on
top of the early bird by using code ny
hack r just like the meetup name and my
hack are get 20 off the conference we'd
love to see everybody there it's gonna
be a really fun time i can't wait to be
back in person and again it will be
virtual for those people who cannot
travel to new york city we want to make
sure everyone is included in this thing
we've got really good at doing virtual
stuff so can't we see everyone there in
person and on screen i'm really super
excited
again barring any variants that destroy
us again
hopefully that will not happen uh we
might all just sort of nicole might lose
it if we have to flip to virtual again
on our watch
um so we have that then lastly questions
it's much harder to ask questions
virtually as we all know by now so if
you have a question about the talk
put it in either the meetup channel and
i'll give you that a second or the zoom
chat so please go to our slack which i
already gave you the link for i think
nicole might so she hasn't posted yet
emily hackguard.org you can find it from
there there is a channel called monthly
meetup chat appropriately named ask your
questions in there go in there let me
know where your pizza place is let me
know where your non-pizza places and ask
your questions in there because i can
copy and paste we'll come up with all
the questions the harder the better and
i will ask them all at the end all right
so hope everyone is excited for this
great talk
i'm very excited about this we've had a
series of talks about analyzing data
that doesn't fit in memory we've had
arrow we've had um
disk.frame i think we had another one
now we have duckdb which i am super
excited about you hear all about this
and i believe i just in another case of
me just asking someone on twitter do you
want to speak and of course everyone's
excited to show off the cool stuff
they're building because everyone's
blowing this great open source stuff
we're all very excited so everyone
please give a good emoji welcome to hans
coming to us from all halfway around the
world at 1am in this timezone so thank
you very much for being here
thanks for having me i'm really excited
let me get going then um yeah
good
afternoon i guess um my name is hannes
and i'm i'm here to talk about duckdb
an in-process analytical database
management system sorry for the the
acronym it's something that i use every
day have been using for the everyday for
the last 10 years or so
um yeah so duckdb is a new system where
we are working on i'm going to tell you
all about it
but first i will briefly introduce
myself um yeah i'm i work at cwi
in amsterdam
which is the dutch national research lab
for computer science and mathematics
um it's the place where python came from
uh
they always mentioned that
um but uh
somehow i got away with working on the r
a lot so it was it was a bit weird but
never mind um
i am one of the uh two creators together
with mark grassfeld of duckdb which is
what i'm talking about
and recently we've also
founded a spin-off company called duct
tv labs around duckdb which is
something that happens a lot in cwi
actually that you know you have a
project it you know
it goes maybe it
grows and grows and grows and then it
becomes a spin-off company because the
research lab has other priorities let's
say
um i am also a former duck parent
which is how duct tape got its name
and i live on a ship which means that
i'm speaking to you from this
floating object right now
that
looks a bit janky maybe from the outside
but i can assure you it's perfectly safe
okay um
let me get started uh so i have like
sort of three main topics for you
tonight the first thing is the general
strained relationship between data
scientists or statistical programmers or
whatever you want to call them
and database management systems
i have i'll talk about what duckdb is
and i will also do a live demo
of you know general behavior of the
thing and uh
obviously uh try to demo some properties
of the system that i think are
interesting
um yeah and of course i will also answer
any any questions you might have and
really happy i'm really curious to hear
that about those so if you have any
questions as jared said let him know
um because really you know uh this is
your opportunity to ask me anything
all right um
this is kind of interesting the strained
relationship of
data scientists and data systems
so data scientists work with data i
think there's a lot of
you know a lot to argue about about data
science
but uh
one one obvious and not not so
controversial thing is that they work
with data
in my field i i mean i work in a
database
management systems research lab has been
like spent like 50 years you know all
the way back from from system r from ibm
has been spent spending like 50 years on
perfecting database management systems
so it's clearly clearly obvious that
data scientists use
database management systems
um but they don't um they they really
they really don't and
uh they they will that will
sometimes you know interface with
database management systems if they're
really forced
for example the
you know this common case of corporate
data sitting
in a database management system already
like in your oracle or whatever and you
having to deal with that in order to do
actually your work
but people generally prefer to avoid
these systems in in general
and there's this nice quote from hadley
here that um
it says if your data fits in memory
there is no advantage to putting it in
the database it will only be slower and
more frustrating and that really hurts
my feelings you know i i think as
somebody who cares deeply about database
management systems
that really got us thinking and it's
it's uh you know these and similar
quotes of course have really you know
been the
that's the motivation to build back to
be in the first place which is i'll get
back to that later
but let's see
maybe data scientists don't really
need database management systems so if
but then i just actually run this data
for you
[Music]
today
um so let's have a brief look at the
most downloaded uh our data wrangling
packages
january 2020 from the rstudio crime
mirror logs and we look at this and we
see this table where you have on the
left column you have the rank
in the download popularity in the middle
of the name of the package and on the
right you have the the download count
and you can see
that you have deep pliers number five
data table is number 31 uh arrow 415 and
of course duck to be one
one one one three and there's this clear
um yeah need for this kind of technology
and also in the r space
so
if you ask yourself what do let's say
deep player data table and arrow and
there's many others
have in common
well
they kind of perform relational
operations it's really strange how you
know how this maps super obvious super
directly to
what you know from relational systems
like selections projections joins
aggregates unions ordering
uh
you know mapping scalar functions the
whole whole thing this is one aspect
the other aspect is the
um support of io let's say like loading
data into our writing data into files
uh for example like loading things like
csv packet files into
there's also an interesting aspect so
from this we can kind of conclude that
the data centers actually need data mms
functionality it's just
that
they really don't like database
management systems it's really
interesting um
and the result is that the community is
kind of reinventing
database management systems but i hate
to say this but rather poorly you know
in in from from my
admittedly ivory tower perspective as a
database systems academic
for example
there is no notion of holistic query
optimization right so if you build a
d-ply pipeline
or a multi-step pipeline data table
doesn't really matter
you will not have a
query optimization step that looks at
the entire pipeline and tries to be
clever about it
it's just going to be a material
materialization after each step
and that leads to materialization of
potentially huge
intermediate results
which is a problem because it's
generally also these things do not
support out of memory computation
so that means because you materialize
large intermediates and because you
don't support out of memory generally
that means things stop working uh to put
it
simply
um
there's also a little parallelism i mean
this is changing a little bit
but
overall because of this single step
notion we also don't have pipelining
which is kind of not the state of which
is kind of the state of the art in
parallel data
systems there's also no something that
i've i've also
wondered a bit about is that there's
also no notion of
transactional storage so
people have somehow completely gotten
used to data management sort of
semantics from the 60s in that sense
that oh i'm writing you this file but my
r process crashes halfway through so now
i have a half a file somewhere
uh and i have to deal with that when
this these are all like solve problems
with transactions
and but somehow
somehow those are not used
so state-of-the-art analytical database
management systems they can so they have
kind of solved all these problems and
you know with this
you know even considering the usual gap
between academic research in
around those systems and what is
actually deployed on the ground
there's actually a lot of firepower
available in
systems it's just that indeed
the current systems that people are
using they can indeed feel very slow and
they can indeed feel very frustrating
but what we kind of set out to do
is to
work on this work on this part
why are they slow and frustrating
because they don't have to be there's no
reason
why
for example the
client server interaction between
you and your postgres server has to
be so slow to be practically unusable
for large data sets you know there's no
reason
you know you have to
first pay an oracle consultant a lot of
money in order to set up a high
performance data management system
um there is
no reason why uh a csv powers in a data
management system has to be the most uh
you know complicated thing to run
in since the since the dawn of time
there's no reason
uh we the database systems have to own
all the data
they can also just uh run on anything
else and this is really not a
not such a huge step so these are
this is the kind of was kind of the
motivation to
to to rethink this a bit and so that's
that's kind of how duct tape came along
so what is duckdb
um so duckdb is something we call an in
process
olap dbms again more acronyms so olap
means online analytical processing it
means
uh yeah it's it's what we do in r it's
the data analysis for
analytical purposes the
other
standard database use cases called otp
which is transactional processing which
is something
that postgres for example is good at
so duckdb is olap so analytics the dbms
is database management system okay
it is in process and that is something
that is quite uncommon and the only
other system that
is of note that is also in process is
sqlite and what is different
from
let's say posgus or mysql or really
anything else is that the database
management system runs within the
process you're trying to access it from
in this case this would be r
um and we have a slide later where i
could talk a bit more about that
um detective is written in c plus 11.
for maximum compatibility we got a lot
of questions why not rust
but
but yeah maximum comfortability
um and duckdb is a sql system
so
that means that it speaks sql uh you
know sql in
in the general case more specifically
we have adopted the postgres syntax
so uh uh yeah it's compatible with
postgresql
on the language level that's that's the
only that's like the the compatibility
um dacdp is also special because we have
we have adopted the principles of the
tiny verse
and built it without any external
dependency and this is something that
comes a bit from
my life at cwi where
our evil admins would not allow us to
install anything and it wouldn't give us
root permissions on our cluster machines
and this was also before there was
something like docker or something like
that
uh and so we had to
you know we had to suffer a lot every
time something had an external
dependency and because from this
experience we developed this deep hatred
of external dependencies and as a result
activity doesn't have any and it turns
out that we are not the only people that
don't have root on their boxes which is
obviously not very surprising so
uh even for people that don't have root
and just cannot they have maybe the
rights to install our packages they can
use duckdb
um back2b is integrated with lots of
stuff so this is just we can talk to
c c plus plus there's a command line
client there is a python interface
there's an r interface there's java node
and so on and so forth
there's a lot of contributed clients as
well i've kind of lost track of all of
them
uh suffice to say is that you probably
will find a way of talking deductibly
from your favorite language
um of course your favorite languages are
uh and so is mine so that's that's
that's good because r is the
uh i would say a focus uh of duct tv
development in general
um dr b has native parque support um
we figured that
it's you know in 2022 a
large scale data management tool
probably needs to be able to speak
rk so we can read and write 4k files
natively again without any external
dependencies which it was fun
and
drb is also integrated with arrow which
is interesting i think because we have a
we actually have a collaboration with
them
with the voltron data people
uh on on improving this this error
support and what we do there what we can
do there is we can basically
pretend like an arrow table is a table
inductdb and run queries on it any query
and we can also export
our query results
back as an arrow table and this
doesn't only work it also works in a
streaming way so we can actually stream
uh through duct tape we can stream arrow
data and kind of round trip it without
actually materializing it ever of course
depending on the query some queries have
to materialize but
for many cases we don't and this is
quite a very exciting integration
um testing yeah dr b um so
many sort of research labs are kind of
notorious for producing software that
looks that maybe proves a point but
isn't over like
isn't terribly useful or still needs a
lot of work so if you look at postgres
history for example and when it came out
of uc berkeley it was practically
unusable um
and it was only the you know the long
sort of iteration and slog of open
source contributors that made this
usable um we thought maybe we can
shortcut this process and we designed it
from from back to be from day one
to be actually
you know
something that people can use and you
know to make it something that people
can use we had to create this giant test
suite of millions of queries that we run
on every commit
in order to make sure the thing still
does the right thing tm um and that is i
think something that is you will it's
pretty rare let's say for this kind of
project
it's pretty common though for commercial
uh systems development
um yeah and actually screen open source
this is something that
is also a bit uncommon let's say in this
space
um especially under a license like mit
license which is very permissive of
course
because
the the technologies that you find in
duct tape
quite rare i would say in the open
source space especially in this
combination we'll talk a bit later about
what those are
um
because this has so far been sort of
these technologies so far have only been
found in or mostly been found in quite
expensive
uh commercial systems
um yeah so uh i mentioned this briefly
dr b is optimized for analytical use
cases so olap so what how this are these
characterized in in more detail well
olap is
uh the characterized by we mostly read
read mostly it's called
so where your
workload we call that sort of the
overall set of queries that you run on
your system yeah you run a lot of
selects and these selects tend to touch
um
a lot of your data
so
if
if you run a if you run a query you will
run
uh on entire columns or you will group
over an entire table or you will
join an entire table with another table
and
yeah so these are fairly complex queries
that touch a lot of the data
you will in terms of updates to your
data you will see mostly bulk appends
bulk as in will append a million rows to
your table or we'll change an entire
column of your table and it's kind of
interesting because
in inductive we have redesigned the
mvcc transactional control mechanism to
actually deal with bulk updates and i
think it's the first system out there it
does that
and the result is that you have full
transactionality
on data storage inductdb with regards to
oh i can start a transaction
start doing this massive update of my
data
decide that i'm going to change my mind
and roll this back all the while
uh 15 other transactions are running
that are looking at the same table
without interfering with each other um i
mentioned before there's something that
has this has kind of been lost
in the let's build our own data tools
um
uh craze um
and this is different so this olap
scenario that's quite different from
what traditional systems are designed
for so if you look at
postgres or mysql or sqlite
those are transactional
systems which means that they have
been designed to support very many
millions
of small very small rights and updates
in very very many millions
of very small queries like okay let's
pull a single row from the table let's
pull a single row update this one field
and then write it back or let's delete a
single row
and this is a very very different
use case than analytical queries and it
leads to very very different trade-offs
when you're designing a system you have
to use very very different data
structures very different
data encodings you have to use you know
different paradigms and overall in
building these query systems
um
yeah and as i mentioned duckdb is
tightly integrated with r i will show
that later but this has really been
something that
has been close to our hearts from the
beginning so i think that we had an r
api from like
you know week three
because we it was important to us that
whatever we were building
uh uh fit well into into that
environment and we have actually made a
ton of design decisions for example uh
with with ductdb so it's still is able
so it's still possible to publish it
through scram which has as you probably
know tons of restrictions regarding what
kind of code you can can use in your
package if you're not cheating
um so why not something else isn't there
anything else well there are other
systems so there is
the existing big data ecosystem for
example you have spark uh you have click
house you have presto these kind of
things um
but uh and it's kind of funny because
sometimes i teach courses
right now i'm teaching a course with
spark
and it's
it's amazing how how difficult to use
these things are
uh
so first of all you have to install
these multi-gigabyte packages of stuff
usually java files
uh have
literally hundreds of external
dependencies
um to install before you can run
something like
click house or impala or whatever
um you have
complex setups you know you need to need
if you want to have multiple computers
to run this this is really the three
night marriage to set up and once
something goes wrong the debugging step
is where i personally lose my mind every
time so
um i find i find it a bit regrettable
that uh
that these existing systems are quite
hard to use which kind of
harks back to the quote from hadley way
is that they are frustrating yes they
can be very frustrating indeed um
then you have also
the um
the dusk
kind of pandas plus plus crowd
and those are you and those are
better let's say because they're more
lightweight
uh in general but um they also lack
optimizers
and therefore cannot do complex queries
without a lot of hand
rolling and that is also not very pretty
so
this is the existing ecosystem is not
something that uh let's say
has convinced me from from a usability
standpoint
and um yeah as already mentioned the
they have this you have this existing
sql landscape and there's usually oltp
heavy
um so in process systems that exist for
example sqlite or pandas or
you know deep flyer
[Music]
they are also not big data capable in
that sense because you have single
thread execution
uh yeah you have this transactional
notion of operation is especially with
sqlite and progress which uh really
leads to something we call a high
cpu cycles per value
cost and therefore
uh very bad performance on large data
sets
and these these systems also don't
really take advantage of modern hardware
uh which activity does and i'll show you
later how it does that
and actually hit this sad hidden truth
kind of that in process olap can support
like 90 of big data workloads there's
been a bunch of papers on this
uh you know on actual
looking at the actual workload sizes of
of typical big data analysis
and
the yeah the sad truth is that 90 of
these workloads
can totally be done on a laptop the only
reason why people don't
use a laptop why people use sparks is
because of the limitation of existing
tools and it's it's uh it's quite
surprising to see how far you can
stretch something like a macbook
uh with something like duckduby uh
you know without going to a spa cluster
we had this
with this experiment where we looked at
this the famous new york taxi data set
um
and we compared
how many
we measured how many spark nodes you
need to beat duckdb on a single machine
on this data set and i think the answer
was 32
so you needed 32 times the hardware on
amazon uh to to beat the single node uh
sort of to beat the performance and that
was i thought quite shocking because you
know we'll basically burn 32 times more
polar bears in order to use spark and
then the question is why right if it's
not necessary
um yeah so here's a picture that i try i
like to use to come to explain where
duct tv fits into this general landscape
we have the in process
and the standalone systems um and we
have the oltp and olap divide
and if you think about it sqlite the
world's most deployed database system is
an in-process otp system uh postgres i
think the most popular open source
database management system is the
standalone
otp system
and then duckdb of course is kind of the
first in-process olap system actually so
we kind of invented that category and if
you wanted to have another
representative of the standalone olap
category you would think of something
like click house right the problem with
the standalone stuff is that
you always have the
client server set up to deal with and
that means that if you were running a
database server just simply for yourself
you have to set it up and you have to
deal with the client protocol panes
which i already briefly mentioned
which means that when you try to pull
data from the standalone system
um
you will it will take you know ages
essentially because all the data has to
go through a socket
and
use in in the case of postgres using
ancient
row-based protocols
maybe this is all fixed now with error
flight sql we shall see
um
yeah so dv adoption
and use cases maybe just a bit
just to show where we are we have about
a hundred thousand downloads a week
right now most of them come from python
um about four thousand github stars
it's going very well we are quite happy
with the adoption on there
400 forks which is sometimes
i wonder why people click the fork
button but it's a different discussion
and we can see two kind of main use
cases for ducktv
at the moment um one is the the scaling
data science workflows use case where as
i just mentioned
you can kind of uh expand the
capabilities
of what you can do in r to you know far
beyond what you would have thought would
be possible
and the other
use case is that people use duckdb
as a building block in very large data
science pipelines or other systems so
we're working with
a bunch of
industry
players there that basically use
portions of duct tv in bigger systems
and that's also how we by the way
finance the duct tape labs operation
um yeah but we are here for the first
bit uh
scale the data science workflows
but how does it do that how does deck to
be actually manage this and i'm going to
talk a bit about the internals
uh and how how the b manages to be
faster
than the others
so
they'll have to talk about queer
processing paradigms
the first queer processing paradigm is
tuple at a time
and this is the the probably the query
processing paradigm that
you think that all systems all sql
systems out there use
so we have
uh for example systems like sqlite
posgress mysql etc
they all use a tuple at a time
and it's it's really a great method if
you are running transactional workloads
because it gets you very small memory
footprint
um you literally have to you can
literally get away with uh
with a static memory allocation which is
what sqlite can do
um
and
this paradigm also kind of comes from a
time when we didn't have memory
but the cost of
double at a time is that we have a high
cpu overhead protable because
we're going for the data in a row wise
fashion which means we have to
constantly switch around between the ti
the types that we look at while going
through the rows because we're not
going through the data in a column major
way but in a row major way and that's
fine for transaction that's actually
great for transactional workloads it's
what you want to do in transactional
workloads
but um
yeah you get the high cpu overhead so if
you're going through a trillion rows
it's going to be slow
the next
query processing paradigm historically
was column at a time
and this is actually what's happening
what's happening if you use our data
frames
because in our data frames data frames
are just lists of
columns of vectors in r and vectors are
just
columns of
native c arrays
in memory and that worked better
so that gets you a better
cpu utilization for your um
for your queries
um and it allows to
use to take advantage of modern hardware
for example
um yeah you were you're able to use sim
the instructions on your data
but it also has a disadvantage because
if you
look at column at a time
queries and you look at longer pipelines
that use column at a time it
materializes huge intermediate columns
in memory
and they can be gigabytes in size and
this gets really problematic when data
sizes are large because it will push you
[Music]
beyond the memory limits very easily
um
it's kind of funny i side note here i
talked to john chambers about this once
because i happen to may make a snarky
comment about how r got this right by
accident
uh to use a columnar representation
and after the talk he he came to me and
you know that
informed me in a very friendly way that
this was not by accident
it's a bit okay
sorry
but um
drb uses a mixture of
robas and columnar
uh query processing paradigms which is
called vectorized processing now there's
always a bit of confusion there because
people think vectorized means simply
but it actually doesn't mean that in our
sense
what it means is we look at data we
process data as a stream
of subsets of columns sort of chunks of
a table
and
this has huge advantages with regards to
cpu cache locality
uh and it allows for example
also to use simply instructions it also
it allows you to use pipelining with
regards to
pipelinable queries
but
it doesn't fill up your memory it uses
very small intermediates
our intermediate results in duct to be
are usually
1024 rows
in size and that means that the
intermediate fits in the cache which
means that
you can actually do
a lot of operations on a single
vector we call it of data without having
to go back and forth from memory and
which is where the speed comes from
okay so
in vectorized processing the
intermediates fit in cache which is
great which is fast
and the reason for that is
that you have this cache hierarchy
um
where in the you have this various
layers cache you've probably heard of l1
l2 l3 cache
and if you look at these cache hierarchy
you see that
you have l1 cache it's very small 32
kilobytes but the latency is one
nanosecond great and in memory you have
maybe
i don't know 64 gigabytes on the latest
macbook um
but then latency is 100 nanoseconds
and this 100x difference there
um really makes a makes a you know makes
a huge impact when you're constantly
going back and forth between the two
and now with vectorized processing
all the things you do fit into these
high cache levels so you don't have this
um
you don't have this problem and it makes
it really fast and in the column of the
time
approach that i've mentioned before
you are kind of forcing intermediates to
go to memory once you do anything
serious which means that things get very
slow regrettably
so that's kind of the
the magic sauce the uh kind of low-level
hacking
c-plus plus kind of uh engine
perspective of course there's a ton of
other things but like that's that's at
the core of why this is different
um
yeah duct tape loves r it's as i
mentioned uh it's kind of interesting
that uh that i'm
talking about duck tv at an r uh meet up
again because
we also announced duck db at an r meetup
a couple of years ago in zurich and
indeed most of the
much of the motivation to build activity
in the first place came from interaction
with our people for especially there
were two i want to mention two people as
thomas lumley and anthony demicko
and these two
both were actually working on analyzing
survey data specifically the american
community survey which
because there are many americans the
survey is quite large
and
they wanted to find a way how to analyze
the survey data set without
because it wasn't possible in r anymore
and that kind of led to a long
kind of working on things together first
with
external like standalone systems and
then
with this idea with the staffed idea of
in process olap which kind of was
developed as a result
and um yeah duck tb is the result of
these interactions which is kind of cool
because it's also something i think in
my field that is quite rare that people
actually talk to practitioners
uh it's it's more it's quite common for
people to
um
you know develop systems put them out
there and not them you know surprised
when nobody cares because they actually
you know haven't talked to anyone and
they they have this sometimes have this
notion of
uh that the world has to
i don't know come to them more often to
acknowledge to people their brilliance
but
you know we see this a bit differently
and we think it's this actually this
interaction with people that makes it
better which is also
one of the reasons why duct tape is open
source and why everyone can complain to
us
on github
um yeah so dr b is on cram
without external dependencies
it fully implements the rdbi um
sometimes we we uh
we talked to kirill who is of course the
uh the guardian of the dbi
and we have some arguments but i would i
would think he would agree that we fully
implement this api
uh directory supports dbplayer we've
just recently merged a
a big pull request um
that
that extended these capabilities but
um in principle because duck to be
speaks equal there's
there's no uh sort of
how shall they say that there's no
problem there you can just
db player will just be able to create
sql queries that have to be understand
and one really important thing
that makes doc to be different from i
think every other database management
system
is that we can efficiently transfer data
to and from r
and how do we do that um
so we inductee itself we have
implemented readers
what we call a scan operator for our
data frames
which means that
yeah we can
pretend like in our data frame is a
table that we operate on and we can
actually in many cases zero copy
the data from the data framing to
our internal vectors that we use for
curve processing
and on the other side this also works i
mentioned is that we support this with
arrow
but we also support this with normal
data frames so we can
take a query result inductively
and we can efficiently turn it into an
into another r data frame
and i think it's pretty unique in that
it's a unique in that is a general
purpose data management system
that is heavily deeply integrated with
uh r
uh to the level where we can read native
data frames
and write native data frames without
a lot of loss of speed
obviously when we talk about
data frames
we have to
mention one
thing which is strings
the strings are usually a curse
um but we have had a quite long running
interaction with uh
with the um the our
core
team and friends about this so in 2014
i demoed um zero copy db uh
database and r integration
at the dsc meeting
and this was this was more like okay
people this is what could work possibly
maybe we can you know work together on
something
um and um
this led to 2016 the being the altrap
framework being
proposed also at dsc
and then it released in 2018
and uh and we were now in 2021 able to
use the altrip framework that we
proposed in 2014
to make string transfer from a to
r and duct to be fast
and it's kind of funny to see that uh
you know
that like like how long this interaction
ran
to produce this outcome
because uh you know you know when i was
i would have never dreamt that we will
ever be able to benefit from this
ourselves but uh here we are and we have
okay
so um
i this was a bit of an overview of what
duckdb is and how it works and now i
would like to go
to a demo
so let me
there's a chat message here but um i
suppose it's a question
oh no something else
um
so
um
uh yeah so i have my uh my shell here i
hope you can see it
i will start air r and now i will
get some script i prepared earlier
and start doing things so here i'm just
loading dbi
which is uh the r standard database
interac
interface
they're making two connections
one is to a postgres server that runs
locally on my mac here and one is the
duct tv connection
that runs inside this very r shell
so
if i look at
this connection you can see that there's
some funky things here and these are
just the pointer addresses of where the
database lives
but this is not
an in memory database like what you
maybe know from
from
sqlite but i'm actually using an on disk
um
data representation in or for fairness
so let me create some some dummy data
um so this is a
it just creates a data frame with 10
million rows
which is not that crazy right but it's
also not very tiny
of just
random
numeric values
columns abc
and now let me do the first experiment
i just talked uh just mentioned that
blackberry was very good at reading data
uh that the transferring data to and
from r now this data frame i just
created my also named data
lives in r right let's try to put this
into postgres
and now here's a command
um that will write this
data this data frame called data
into my porsche sql server that i have
running here on my computer so this is
not like a remote or anything it's just
the same machine
and um i'm just going to write this in
and now it's done
and because of this
uh time thing here it will will print
the time it took so
12 seconds so this
is not a crazy large
data frame we just brought this into our
possible server and take 12 seconds okay
you might think this is not a lot but
obviously then i'll make the data set
bigger
if i use this if i do the same thing
with duckdb we're done in 0.4 seconds
and why is this so much faster
because this is effectively also just
writing i mean in the end both of both
of these commands write to disk because
they write they told the tell database
management system to write a new table
to disk
which you know on the same machine the
disk speed is constant so that's not a
factor
the factor is that of course two things
one it's the
the client servant server overhead that
happens
when i talk from r to my postgres server
and second it's that duckdb is just also
generally faster of writing tables to
disk so now we already seen one
experiment
let's do another one let's do the other
direction
let me pull my data frame back into
our from postgres now this is a bit
should be a bit faster
because it's um
[Music]
it's reading not writing and you can see
in roughly six seconds we were able to
read this data frame back into r and now
we have the same
so if i if i look at
should have our 10 million rows back
uh and we do okay
now let's read the same data frame back
from
from duckdb
and it's 0.1 seconds
um
and this is really a game changer so but
this allows you for example is to
really pull huge amounts of data from
persistent storage into r
and do some operational and then write
it back in a transactional way
without having to
um yeah wait and this allows for example
iterative computation and things like
that that would otherwise not be
possible
and now just for the laws i'm fitting a
linear model to this
data um and which takes 1.8 seconds and
this is kind of what i'm you know it's
just just as a comparison so if i if i
spend 1.8 seconds to fit the linear
model but i've just spent six seconds to
load the damn data
that seems a bit
like an imbalance you know you would
think the fitting of a model is more
complicated than reading a data set
and it is
which is why if we read this thing from
duckdb
it compares much better because it's
only 0.1 seconds
to read the data versus 1.8 seconds to
fit the model seems fair
let me talk about strings i've mentioned
strings are a bit of a curse so
let me just now run a bunch of queries
where i'm just going to cast
one of the columns in my data set
to a string
but i'm going to do that in database so
on the other side of the fence so to
speak
and now i have to wait again
oh yeah there we are okay so now both of
this both systems have done that
and converted 10 million strings
it doubles to strings which is
somehow also slow
and now again i can i can run this
timing of the data after pulling the
data now it's just one column
from postgres
to r and i will run the same thing um
[Music]
in inductive so here now we took eight
seconds for the single column which i
think is pretty bad
and if i do the same thing in ductdb
it's only half a second
and actually i can use this uh
i can use this i can show you this
i can actually show you this this low
level print of the
of the
of the structure of the object and you
can see
that here at the very bottom of this
data frame you don't have an actual
normal string column but a duckdb string
column which is a
an altrap
object that looks like a normal r string
vector
but actually isn't uh and it will
like delay the conversion to an actual
rs text
for uh performance reasons so this is
why duct tape is much faster there
it's because we use ultra which we
invented ourselves which is great
um
let me show you a bit the data frame
scan
so inductively what you can do is i can
of course i have this in famous mt cars
data set here i can
say
please register this data frame mt cars
in my duckdb connection under this name
mt cars
and now what i can do i can run
queries
so as you can see up here
now i've just given this an arbitrary
sql query this is the most common
difficult query of course the secret
select start from table
and it's reading from this empty cards
table which i've just registered up here
and the cool thing is that this
register step actually doesn't copy
anything
it just it just registers the fact and i
mentioned this earlier duct tape can
directly
read data from our data frames it just
directly registers the
data frame inductedbe and says okay drb
listen there is a data frame
empty cars that you should expose to sql
users under the name mt cars
and you can really run any query here
that you like
maybe i can show you an explain output
that shows
never mind this is fixed in the latest
master but not yet on the crown
if you look at the query plan
you will see that
on the bottom of the plan where normally
you have the table scan it will say our
data frame scan
and duct tape can also read can also
read
parquet files so if i if i just
um i will just show you that as well so
if i
just sorry about that i have to
i have to
fin find the link to a parquet file here
um
[Music]
so i can also do something with ducktv
get query
this is just normal dbi right
so
duckdb
select star from
and now i can just use the parquet file
name as a table name and this is
something that works in duckdb
so i will just point this 2d
okay file and say i don't know limit 10
[Music]
ah so it's condd sorry
and as you can see
now i have the result like some some
columns that come from this parquet file
and again this does not actually import
the data into ductbee i'm just
creating a scan
over a package file and it works because
duckdb has
built in support for parquet and we we
know that this is a per k file because
we look at the table name that you're
using in this query
um
and we um
we find that we use this extension you
can also make this explicit also works
with wild cards
also works with s3 you know whatever
okay let's um do more experiments
i'm gonna
read another data frame
from an rds file which is called line
item
this is a data set that is a synthetic
data set
uh
from the tpch benchmark
uh yeah it's a benchmark data set that
is used a lot in data management
research
uh and it's something that yeah we also
end up using a lot
so here we have
the line item data set and um
now i can
use this
waiting game again to write this data
set which has
i think something like six million rows
uh you can configure of course how many
rows you want but for benchmarking
purposes i just use the six million size
now again i have to wait
until this ancient postgres technology
has managed to transfer
this data set over the socket
from r because this data set i've loaded
in ours as a from the rds
file now i just have to wait until this
has been
transferred
and now i should have a
uh what is it the jeopardy waiting music
or something like that
and this is really the worst part if you
have a live demo and something takes a
while because
this feels like much longer than it does
when you try this out
but i hope it's done soon
[Music]
hopefully it doesn't crash there we are
42 seconds that's that's kind of perfect
isn't it and now let's do the same thing
with duckdb
it takes a little bit longer because
there's more string columns in here
um but
four seconds yay
and now let's have a look at this at
this data set
um using d player so i have a
this is just gonna copy paste because i
can't type this fast i'm just gonna have
a
function here
that uh does a bunch of quite common
data operations so it
it will um filter
the uh the data here
to say okay this this column needs to be
smaller than the state
we do a group by and the summarize
where we say okay we group by two of
these columns we do a bunch of summarize
computations like aggregates
then we do an arrange sorting
and print the result and now um i can of
course run this directly using d plier
and this is the same
and
i can also
run this using db player
and as you can see i get the exact same
result
what i can also do
is i can run this through
uh i could also run this through the
data frame scan directly
but
yeah that's a different
that would be the same result again so
that's that
um
so that was the demo
let me get back to my
slides
i actually don't have the i only have a
wrap-up slide here and
so
if you
just as a
please if you want to hear more about
duck tb
uh you can join us at our user group
meeting our first one which is in april
we have a discord server
you can follow us on twitter
uh but before you do that we uh i'd
really like to discuss some questions
that have come up
and um two have already come up by jared
himself
um
and um maybe if you like we can also
discuss
um you know what kind of things we think
are gonna you know be added to duckdb in
the next year or so but two questions
came up already were
what about uh um
g support uh geographical systems and
this is something that
we're working on
uh it's not entirely clear yet because
the problem with
gis and databases is that
um
the yeah postgis is this kind of
state-of-the-art thing
but it's using postgres and as i just
explained to you postgres really is not
great for analytical use cases
and
postgres as an implementation is quite
row heavy as well so
um we don't think we can use it
so we'll have to do something else there
but we're working
like we're also looking at the
developments in the aerospace on on that
and
kind of curious how that goes
um and that's also the jit question and
that's actually a different question i
think it was a gpu question
do it as duct tape we have gpu support
it does not
uh we don't think it's necessary it's
fast enough as it is but with that i'd
like to um
yeah here's some other questions
maybe i can
stop sharing my screen for a bit here
so thank you very much uh give everyone
you have a nice little emoji clap
in the chat let us uh
show hanas our our appreciation for this
great talk
um thank you yep so i know i already got
some uh not questions but comments about
people who love the tiny verse uh
reference there
um or actually could you explain to
people who very well a lot of people are
gonna be very aware of the tidy verse
but fewer people are probably where the
tiny verse could you maybe just let the
crowd know about that
absolutely um so i'll just show you this
on on in
this is something that is a bit of a
rant uh
uh by a bunch of people from the uh yeah
our world i think this is where it comes
from
um
and it's also a bit of a stab at the
tidy verse so i'm not i don't want to
get into the uh
into sort of the details of that beef
but uh
the the tiny words the idea is that
uh we should be careful with
dependencies and
i think that is that is uh
a good idea um
and it says in on this website uh
tinyverse.org it says every dependency
you add to your project is an invitation
to break your project and it's something
that we've
me like being a software developer for i
don't know 20 years
uh have have learned too much how true
this is let's say
um and it's also why
i'm uh i'm super very when i see systems
like click house or impala and and they
have hundreds of dependencies
in order to just run just build and run
them
and that's that's just such an extremely
brittle setup and it takes only one
tiny little thing
to to change to make the whole thing
come crashing down and this happens a
lot which is why nowadays you can't
actually build these systems anymore
yourself because
the environment has that they need to
build has degraded so far that there's
only the only way to build them is
through their docker container for
example you know which you might say is
not a big deal but it is a big deal if
you want to be a cram package for
example
now on cram it's in our it's actually
quite convenient to add dependencies to
your project and thanks to the
tireless efforts of the crime
maintainers of course the package
quality generally is okay
uh compared to other things
however the same thing applies right now
we have
giant reverse dependency trees
uh and before somebody can change a
package
these these enormous checks have to run
and they still miss things and they
still break people's things and and this
problem just multiplies and i guess
statistical people should be
not surprised that if you add more
dependencies then this problem becomes
uh much worse uh um super linearly worse
let's say
because of just the chance of
anything uh breaking in one of your
dependencies and something that many
people don't realize is also the
transitive dependencies right because
you depend on something
and that depends on 10 other things and
each of them depends on other things and
there's actually this yeah we get this
hair ball of a graph that for dependency
graph that basically means at some point
everything is dependent on everything
and yeah
nothing works anymore so we've made a
very conscious decision
to limit dependencies to
one we have one grand package dependency
which is dbi which we kind of need to
have
and it's also an r only package and
otherwise you know
yeah this is really important to us and
i think
um
yeah it's just because i haven't
personally suffered so many times trying
to install things
that we've really tried to keep this you
know to learn from sqlite
and just have no dependencies
it's funny one of those supporters of
the tiny verse dirk out of battle
yeah eastwood in the package probably is
the most dependent on rcp has like 8 000
reverse dependencies because it's such
an important package this is not his
fault though
does this fall for making such a great
package so
well it's not his i mean okay but he but
of course then imagine
then if if
if if derek starts depending on
rando stuff that breaks he breaks every
single package that depends on him so i
think that's that's really a problem
and we if people want to learn more
about this um we had a talk of the
conference a few years ago by
self-described town crank jeff ryan
about how your api is a promise and
about not having dependencies i remember
i very purposely scheduled jeff ryan's
talk to be right after david robinson's
talk because they were complete
opposites of each other and that was
really fun and one of my favorite photos
ever jd long took a photo of them at the
bar right house afterwards of jeff and
david like going at it at the bar with
whiskey in their hands and it was a
really really great picture
yeah
i think this is this is this is true i
think it's fine to depend on tons of
stuff
if you're the if you're the lowest
in the in the sort of in in the tree if
you if you are writing
your own package to do something that
you need to do for your work if you
depend on 100 things
fine
you know if you if this breaks it's only
you are affected but if you're building
a something like duct tape which is
supposed to be a building block for tons
of things
we have to be much more careful so i
think the zero dependency is also much
more relevant if you are building a
library that other people depend on
than it is if you're building um you
know a
end-user thing
of course even as an end user if you are
a scientist and you need to go back to
work six months later but all of a
sudden something's changed you as a
scientist need to relearn that part of r
but you're supposed to be doing like
chemistry or something
yeah yeah and then you have things like
you know people not updating packages
for this reason or like snapshotting
packages with docker in order to work on
this problem
which you know both solutions i i'm not
sure about you know it's
cool uh i know we had fun getting
sidetracked there let's continue on with
the questions um this isn't a question
but uh brian lewis is in the crowd and
he was there it looks like at your d the
2016 dsc discussion about alt rep um so
he just gives you a comment this is this
is more awesome than you could have
imagined so that's not a question but a
great comment from brian lewis another
long-time member of the community
yeah that's oh yeah
oh that's super cool yeah uh yeah brian
hi brian um
yeah this is this is really something
that that uh i didn't expect yeah i said
this i mean this was this was super cool
you know i'm also also a big shout out
to the our core team for making this
happen
um you mentioned you already cut me off
of the head about the gis because you
know i've been pinging you about that on
twitter
but until the js analytics is ready i
have a question this is from me now not
from someone else is my question um
can i store a geometry column or for
that matter any custom column in duct tv
i won't use even processing if i want to
store it yeah um of course you can there
is support for blobs
which are just binary objects however
this is a bit sub optimal because then
you have to kind of find a way how to
transform complex things to
serialize and serialize i think what's
nice is that we have this support for um
for structured things we call them
structs they are nested types so you can
make a type that is
a
a string an integer
a list of things another string or
something like that you can define these
types um
and then you can yeah basically map your
custom thing to that that's that's
usually what
you know people will do with custom
stuff it's also how we expect to support
the gis structures kind of as a
as a struct type we call them struct
types bit like c structs
and the cool thing is that we
can actually store these structs also in
a column away
therefore it's fast to process on them
oh wonderful
and i'm gonna selfishly can we have a
timeline in that like two days two weeks
not longer than that on the gis yeah
um we have an intern starting on this uh
so this but uh
i think there is a lot of low-hanging
fruits um
it also we also depend a bit on the
interaction with the community so on on
what is actually something that you need
to be there for you for this to be
useful to you um
so that's something that um
that is still a bit up in the air i
would say
okay
cool i'll i will pester you more on
twitter so we'll get out of the pools
um how would this um ductdb this being
ductdb handle like time series data um
and both storing it and also computing
on it
it is a very good question because we
have uh richard who i think is here who
who has been working a lot on window
functions um
and this is i think the way in which sql
databases are gonna
demolish the
the sector of specialized time series
databases that have sprung up in the
recent years
because i'm not sure if you're aware of
window functions
in sql but you are okay so those um can
do a lot of the things you would
normally want to do on time series
because they have this notion of going
over the data in a kind of a
localized kind of way and you can look
in the environment of your row and
things like that you can also run like
folds and you can
run custom functions we're working on
making
custom functions possible on
window functions
and i think that's the way that this is
going to be won is by general purpose
systems basically making window fit
systems making window functions fast
which we have
richard has done a lot of work on that
inductive
it still has to be done but i i think it
already works perfectly well to this
time season analysis
um we still have to work a bit on the
the user interface let's say uh you know
what if you have a custom function you
want to run
in as part of your time series
um and we have to do a bit of still more
uh performance engineering on them as
well
but in general i think is the way you
should go you should do like normal
sequel
for time series stuff
i'm gonna throw in here the only thing
i'm worried about window functions are
pain in the butt to write
right
there they're ugly compared to regular
sql so you can find a way to make it
ugly but i mean maybe maybe we can map
this to d flyer somehow you know and say
okay
is a here's an api for window functions
that we exposed to r
that makes this
i'm sorry the slider package by i think
um von davis uh
implements that that might be your
i'm not i'm not entirely aware of i'm
not aware of this but yes something like
that where you have a nice api on
um yeah
and i believe in addition to the slider
package which is like it's like per but
for sliding windows there is a um
i think an rcp rcpp role by kevin ushi
and i believe probably xts probably has
something so there's lots of things you
can get inspiration from yeah yeah i
think this is this is super interesting
stuff i mean
i haven't i haven't uh spent a lot of
time on it myself but i've been we've
been talking to people that are in the
kind of
the time series uh world and uh
it's it seems to be the way to go
yes i know there's a lot of like there's
the old history pi databases but now
there's like um influx db and time scale
yeah yeah which which by the way yeah
yeah exactly but i think i think this is
another case what i've complained about
with the r community reinventing query
processing uh where the time series
people now invent green and
pre-processing
for one specific purpose without
realizing that they're just basically
rebuilding systems that exist that don't
just don't
are not well suited yet for their use
case but
[Music]
yeah
that's just a
just a bit of a rant there
so since you have a analytic database
and for competition um is there does it
already exist and if not is in the
pipeline to be able to fit like
regressions in database or boosted trees
or any other learning algorithm we do
have regressions actually
um
so
i'm sorry like the whole glm family
no no um we have we have some basic
regression
um
in in principle the um the story that we
have there is to say because the data
transfer from our 2r is fast
you can do a lot by pulling the data
which would be not possible with other
systems and of course whatever you can
express in sql you can do um i think
what this is gonna the way this is gonna
work is by people building wrappers that
um use to ship part of the computation
to the system to the relational uh you
know model in terms of sql queries and
then use a bit like what h2o is doing
and then use a you know some logic on
top
to finalize the computation i think
that's the way this is gonna this is
gonna end up but yeah we have a we have
a ton of uh aggregate functions
that are specialized to support these
kind of use cases so
um for example we have already we have
things like
um yeah the the basically uh
of these quantile computations we have
all these regression like the linear
regressions all it's all built in i can
post a link if you like please do show
us an example of a regression of c on
dna uh that's this i cannot pull off
sorry
uh in
fair enough okay so that's really
exciting having been like you know you
say you can move the data out fast but
sometimes the data is just too big to
pull into memory so it'd be nice to be
able to do the regression a penalized
regression even right there in the
database
all right cool i'll add that to you on
twitter in six months i'll be like hey i
want penalized aggression yeah
it's twitter based development
um
so you did sort of decry
docker containers but there's a question
about do you have any pre-baked docker
containers like with the volumes already
ready to persist the data to disk
because some people it's not for
dependencies they just don't want to
install anything
um
do we have no we don't have tribal
docker containers um uh
yeah i mean i recently tried using
docker on my mac and it ended up using
qemu because of the m1 thing
and uh and i i i thought i think it
would just be it's just
if you're running a data analysis
through qemu then this is gonna be
absolutely slow anyways now um i'm not
opposed to creating documentation but
what you do would you you suggested a
use case that was pre-built for what oh
basically so like you know
let's say you're using a database and a
docker container like postgres even you
don't want the data living in the
documentary you want volume to disk
somewhere right you have like a
pre-built docker image and a docker
compose that goes with it that you know
makes the volumes for you
okay but you can also just use duct to
be and directly use the file on disk
assuming that you can install ductdb
which
which is good that's right you can do
that it is not difficult
so we have we have like prebuilt
binaries you can download those you can
just download the art the rpex python
package doesn't pip install duckdb will
get you duckdb i mean it's not
it's not it's not it's a 10 megabyte
download or something like that yeah the
docker container will be far bigger i'm
sure
yes
[Laughter]
all right
no dependencies yay
that makes a difference
yeah and then speaking of large data
there was a question about someone has a
very large sql light file that they pop
up by just appending to it they want to
know can they import that deducted b and
i guess get rid of sqlite or maybe not
current but you know they won't be able
to import it yeah that's a great
question and i have been secretly in the
background preparing something
uh because i saw the question um so we
are gonna release something soon that's
called the sequel light scanner and the
way this works is it's going to be an
extension to duckdb
um and you can kind of oh yeah i've just
loaded already
um and what it does it allows you to
read sqlite files as if they were duckdb
duct to be tables so what i can do here
is i can
okay so okay i've already done this but
you can basically say
sqlite attach
and then
point to a name of a sqlite file
and what this will do
is we'll expose all the
uh tables that are in the sqlite file as
ductdb tables so for example this here
in this um
in this uh
sakila.db it's a standard
test file for sequel light i have a
table called
film so i can just use that
and query it and you can see okay this
looks a bit stupid okay i don't know
i can just query this
this film database as if it were a
normal duct tv table but if you look at
the query plan here
you will see that at the bottom of this
query plan there is no duckdb table but
there is the sqlite
file that
contains this this table and the cool
thing is we can do this ten times faster
than sqlite itself can read this file uh
because we parallelize the the scan of
the sqlite file um
while using their own infrastructure so
that's uh
that's something that we're gonna gonna
release uh super soon uh it's just that
we haven't gotten around to it yet
okay then follow-up question to that
let's say you have a bunch of data in
csvs or parquet yeah
is the mission to
use duckdb to process those csvs and
parquets or is it better to
import those csvs and parquets into a
ductdb storage and then process it yeah
that's a great question um and i think
it depends the answer is gonna be it
depends um
if you if you have a read-only workload
and your data is stored in parquet files
um we have a very competitive parker
reader uh which is able to read those
parquet files very quickly
and since you're only reading them um
you are you you probably don't gain a
lot a lot
from putting it introductively native
storage right
um now with a csv file it's a bit
different and the csv file you get a lot
by importing this introductory because
it becomes smaller we have compression
compression built in
and of course it becomes much much
faster to read the csv file the next
time you want to read it so there you
gain you also of course would like would
want to import this into duckdb um
storage
if you're
trying to do any kind of updates on this
right if you're trying to
modify this like you have like
maybe you want to load this and then
re-encode some of the columns or you
want to
drop some data that looks funky and then
you you really want to use this be able
to use transactional
updates on on this and then you would
import
but
but in general um yeah so that's for csv
i think it's clear that you would want
to do this because of performance
and overall you would want to do this in
case you have
updates you expect changes to the data
which of course you cannot change a 4k
file on disk of course we can also write
to new parquet files but
um i i really i'm really trying to to
get people to stop
re-implementing their own transaction
mechanism based on flat files this is
really uh
that's really bad
yeah
uh and you mentioned for windowing
functions writing custom functions um
let's just talk about deep flyer you
write your own custom function you want
to use in a mutate or to summarize can
they call that in data and dot tv
uh that's actually something i'm working
on right now um and what we
and that's that's gonna come to kind of
come to dr b
um
with the custom functions uh which is
some we're gonna solve this through
something we call user defined functions
and we we have also done this in the
past
uh demo this uh
i think
maybe we've also downloaded it now i've
demoed it as user in uh
good question where was that i think was
it in spain
anyways
um basically the um
we we can automatically create user
defined functions um
from our inductee be using
and then call those during query
processing from duckdb again we can call
your functions
the only restriction is there that
that doesn't work really well with
parallelism because r doesn't allow you
to paralyze
and to run to run functions at the same
time
much like python
yeah we're going to talk about r is not
parallel so same with python the same
way but a way around that we're thinking
about that actually about with this
particular topic a way we're thinking to
fix this and this is going to be
something we're going to build probably
also for python
um
is to
have uh to basically be able to fork off
additional processes
that we we stream the data through that
go that runs in the query
order so we can parallelize so that we
then we would be able to do that but uh
forking has uh
its own let's say
problems especially when you're forking
a
process with potentially gigabytes of
memory attached to it
that's problematic that's even more
problematic on windows and so i i'm not
entirely sure about the you know the
mechanics of that but we have done some
some prototyping on this and
we will start with udfs
um
and i think what we also want to do is
to allow you i mentioned this before for
the window functions that you want to be
able to do scalar udfs where you just
you know value in value out but you also
want to have something where you
use our functions to compute an
aggregate for example and that's a bit
more involved but
we'll have to we'll have to deal with
that
is it i do see that richard wrote that
if you want to write c plus which i
don't you can write
for that
um yes you can write you can write udfs
in c plus plus that's right you can also
i think we have some basic python
support for udfs but
okay
and then a question actually jeff asked
last question i was going to ask can you
control parallelism it's like if you
have if you're calling this as part of a
parallel process you don't want the
using of all the cores so how do you
control parallels
sorry about that yeah you can view it as
a pragma
you can say pragma
threads equals to four and then we'll
use four threads now when you say pragma
is that like is part of your sql query
is that that is a sql query yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you're just positive
queries from r actually could you show
it others yeah yeah yeah so you would
just be like uh come from r it would be
db execute
con
something like that okay
and then it uses four threads for as
many as you want
like default we use all threads i think
that's what it is sort of like data
table like data table uses all threads
but it can tell that if you're calling
that within a parallel context it
reverts down to one thread
oh interesting um yeah uh no i mean this
it tends to be a good default to use all
threads because
it's quite rare that like this is the
default that's what you want you want
your default to be fast right we had a
talk from henrik uh i think berkshire
and i have against his name right hammer
uh he was like writes the future package
he's like the best default is one thread
this way you don't screw up people's
computers and other people using it oh
henry yeah i know yeah i actually know
him uh
um yes i'm sorry about that but
it doesn't matter you know if you if
you're if your default is one then
everybody's gonna use one and only like
the die hards are gonna set this to
anything more and they're gonna complain
to us on our on our github that it's
slow and then we have this is a
documentation problem i have like a like
a training problem in that sense
i hope henrik's watching so you two can
duke it out on twitter no no i mean
never watch it he's a very nice guy oh
you don't know that's why it's gonna be
fun
i wouldn't want to duke anything out
with him
there i think i was in the room and he
when he showed the future package for
the first time it was fun oh that's
awesome you're in a lot of the good
rooms at the right time
and just the our community is so
friendly you know this is why i tend to
hang out hang out at their events the
database community is very unfriendly in
comparison uh this is really something
that has that has that has opened my
eyes in terms of how conference should
be run for example
come to myr you'll see the friendliest
conference you'll ever see
yeah and if and we we pride ourselves on
our food too
yes that is the thing that's not a thing
in holland
we serve ice cream sandwiches and pizza
and beer for our conference
oh beer is a good idea uh
do you have another question not about
food um have you compared a benchmark
against tile db
uh no but uh i'm not particularly
impressed with tile db so uh
yeah
so jerk's not watching now
i think yeah there's an honest opinion
or you know you could all talk friendly
cool
all right
um
that's all the questions i compiled well
i was going to girly about gpus but you
did say yeah it's fast enough already so
you know let that go
yeah sorry i mean i think it's
definitely there's there's this thing
that people try i mean okay just for the
people without context i i think gpus
and sql queries don't go that well
together because the
um the uh the cp processing overhead
that you do in a well-designed system
per value for example is quite low
compared to what gpus generally i could
act good at so you lose a lot of you
lose a lot of things for a very
questionable gain when you move sql to
gpus right for example um you have very
little memory um you know you have to go
from 64 gigabytes of memory to four
uh and suddenly you have to do all these
crazy things in order to make the data
set fit you have
you know it takes time to to move data
there and so on but it's also just a
huge nightmare for engineering you know
you you like writing sql systems is hard
writing gpu systems is harder
and uh and uh yeah so so it's um
so with you know if if you don't need to
why would you it's but
what i wanted to say is it's cool you
know so you can you can get you can get
investors very excited about it and you
can also get nerds very excited about
that
so so it's something that to me seems
like it's done mostly because
it's cool and looks great but
i haven't yet seen a gpu database
benchmark that has convinced me let's
say that this is a feasible or a great
idea in general fair enough fair enough
it's like i know that i've been excited
about because i'm looking for faster
queries and i looked at you know pg
strom i think it's out of japan it's
post guys on a database on gpu ouch
it but ouch yeah and their query show
it's fast but um it's hard to install
because you know oh yeah oh that's also
a problem because yeah you have to deal
with all this driver nonsense
yes that's
yeah that's not fun and we want people
to be able to use duck to be wherever
you know so it's uh
and i'm just going to throw in one more
thing about i know the voltron folks is
made up of an nvidia guy um his name's
escaping right now but they're talking
about arrow on that's actually some of
the actually that's how um pg strom
works and i think um some of the cudf it
uses arrow yeah you so now that you have
the voltron folks there i just got to
push out there i'm going to text wes and
like hey get honest to uh work on this
just
we talked we talk to them regularly so
so that's uh i i know they are they are
working on this udf thing
um
i think i think it's depend on what you
do you know if you do ml or if you do
any kind of more
if you do anything that is more complex
than running a sql query i think it
makes loads of sense yeah
um
but not for what we do
i get it that's fair
very fair
all right cool so i got to give everyone
else just one last chance oftentimes
when i say okay we're all done someone
sneaks in one more question that's the
way the world works so
i will just go over some closing
announcements and if a question comes in
we'll happily turn this over first
before i do any closing another round of
just little emoji or golf claps for
hanas that was an excellent talk i
really really enjoyed that
i do want to say thank you honest for
responding to me on twitter and agreeing
to do this
i think this is awesome hopefully one
day i will get to have you here in
person
um i'll bring you over to new york and
you'll have you know they'll come give a
talk again or just come enjoy someone
else's talk
um
coming up again next month bill gold
we'll be talking about the brooklyn
bridge and how it relates to data
science amongst other things i think the
brooklyn bridge is really that that
really is a good hook
we have david robinson in april we have
the
um new york r conference in june 8th
through 10th there are workshops and
conferences we will be putting on a stan
workshop sometime this summer with jonah
gabriel rob trangucci andrew gelman some
other people from the stand team
um so we're very excited about that we
do that every summer and we'll just
figure out when we're doing it this
summer
um we if anyone actually wants to have
other workshops that we put on as part
of the community we put on workshops
that we bring in an open source
developer and
you know we charge a fee that we
essentially funds open source
development let us know we'll find the
open source developer maybe honest we'll
give a uh a whole workshop you never
know that's really how it happens uh
some people give me an idea what they
want and then i go say hey go talk and i
arrange it
so we have that
remember always visit
nyhackguard.slack.com with this nice
meetup community going
also if you want to see videos
nyhackar.org has 12 to 13 years of
slideshows and videos that you can go
and just click on the presentations tab
and search for a topic or a speaker and
you can see so much cool stuff
likewise rstats.ai has a whole about
seven years worth of videos now from two
different conferences and we also have
our government focus conference so it's
really about like 10 different
conferences worth of videos
so check out that lots of content out
there available for you to enjoy
i did see there was a question and i
just want to make sure that hannah's got
answered out loud are there plans or
foreign keys in duckdb and they've loved
using duck to be but are they going to
be foreign keys
uh yeah yeah we're gonna we're gonna
support those uh there's a currently a
pr somebody else actually did that
amazingly
um but uh but yeah this is gonna happen
uh mainly because people like foreign
keys and we are of course database
populists so we do what the people want
well then since you're working with
corel closely you could probably use the
dm package to uh make it uh
kirill is yeah yeah we work in a lot
with kirill as well um
and um
he's
i'm told the m works fine
but i haven't used it myself
karil gave one of the last in-person
talks i believe january february 2020.
uh let's go to my hacker.org and search
for cruel and he talked about the dm
package so folks are cool
yeah yeah we get back we get people
passing through new york cities all the
time we get all these people from all
around the world it's amazing
cool
all right so that was like our sneak in
question i think hey everyone go to
myhackguard.org to see more um and just
one more round of applause for a great
speaker and everyone should go enjoy
their night their day or whatever it is
and we let hannah's go back to sleep as
it is thank you so much
thank you very much everyone and we'll
see you virtually and in person
virtually next month in person hopefully
soon after that bye everybody